à
m
et
la voix de tania boristhène en fusion et
celle des collégiens de vingt sept
boulettes dans les hauts de saint leu
c'est une rencontre rempli d'émotions
pour l'artiste mais également pour les
jeunes la musique comme vecteur de
connaissance la musique pour découvrir
sa culture et une langue le créole
si on veut avant tout transmettre
a moins comme le vent
en menant au chili
ah oui c'est un moment très important et
les lycées et enrichissant en fait ben
voilà il est laid enfin il ya pourtant
d'autres choses ou alléchant joie belle
façon c'est la relève aussi des enjeux
sans et puis s'est fait plaisir et que
me soit azote de 2,2 d'avoir des futurs
musiciens parmi saison vers la
rencontrer et globalement c'est la
relève qui continue d'en rire quand à
échanger et poser des questions pour
découvrir l'auteur compositeur tania
boristhène a écrit des textes qui
parlent d'elle et de la réunion
forcément sa poésie touche ses élèves de
6e et de 5e
grâce à ce travail les collégiens se
sont familiarisés avec la langue créole
mais également avec la musique de l'art
ils ont chanté des chansons craint parce
qu'en musique on ne fait pas forcément
serein et que j'aime bien choisis donc
bien ça m'a plu ça m'a plu pas sûr bah
on voit pas souvent des artistes est
donc assez bien ça comme ça on
s'intéresse plus elle est comme à 10 à
l'eau mais c'était bien parce qu'on n'a
pas vraiment l'habitude de faire des
chansons en créole et comme je ne sais
pas vraiment parler créole mais ça m'a
appris à a+ développer mais avec tamia
tania comme elle chante super bien
baisse découle pas changé jusqu'à
l'école on apprend plutôt des chansons
française et créole ça change un peu
via pas forcément tout le temps des
chansons créoles donc là c'est un peu la
première que j'apprends au collège et
c'était important pour toi que d'hommes
que d'apprendre une chanson comme la wii
pour changer un peu que français
français français au travail pédagogique
mené dans le cadre de l'opération
collège en musique une manifestation
orchestrée par le conseil départemental
un travail qui s'inscrit donc dans le
projet éducatif en hausse à une place
très importante en tant que professeur
d'éducation musicale et puis cet échange
réel vivant en direct avec un artiste
c'est effectivement très important et ça
concrétise le travail qu'on a pu faire
durant toute l'année
chanter pour n'est pas oublié mais
également pour s'ouvrir aux autres et
partager c'est en musique et avec un
classique du maloya inscrit au
patrimoine de l'unesco que la rencontre
se termine mousse
mais la voix de tania boristhène
résonnera encore longtemps dans la tête
et dans le coeur de nos jeunes
marmailles qui n'attendent qu'une chose
partir à la découverte de leur histoire
la moulée l'attendait